this morning we're hearing more
first-hand accounts from alleged sex
abuse victims of Jeffrey Epstein
Epstein's estate and his alleged
associates are facing new lawsuits
through the child victims act despite
his apparent suicide molla Lange he is
outside the convicted sex offenders New
York City townhouse molla good morning
what a victim saying oh good morning
Tony one of the alleged victims now
suing Jeffrey Epstein's estate says four
women helped him run his alleged
underage sex trafficking operation at
least in part from right here his
roughly seventy seven million dollar New
York City townhouse now Epstein may be
gone but the demand for justice is
intensifying oh good I'm sorry what just
would have been good enough you know
like because I didn't deserve that I
didn't deserve to like just not be a
teenage girl anymore
Michelle Licata says she did not want
Jeffrey Epstein to die she wanted him
behind bars for allegedly sexually
abusing her when she was around 16 years
old I just wanted him to sit there like
I had to sit there after it happened
Licata says a friend recruited her to
give the financier a massage at his
Florida home when she was in high school
and hoping to earn some extra money for
Christmas presents she agreed now 31
Licata is calling for Epstein's alleged
accomplices to be held accountable she's
not alone on Wednesday Epstein accuser
Jennifer arose filed a civil suit
against Epstein's estate and his
purported ex-girlfriend ghilane Maxwell
a Rose is also suing an alleged
recruiter a secretary and made on
Epstein staff Kimberly Lerner is one of
our roses attorneys was there anyone
else who should be held accountable
there were various secretaries there
were housekeepers and there was the
recruiter we haven't been able to
identify any of those people by name as
of yet the lawsuit claims a rose was
recruited when she was 14 she alleges
the abuse began about a month after
meeting Epstein when he showed her the
massage room in his palatial New York
City townhouse and told her it's my
favorite room according to the suit
their visits eventually became routine a
maid would put towels and lotions out
tell
to get changed in the bathroom and leave
her $300 in cash for each visit about a
year after the alleged abuse started
arose claims Epstein forcibly raped her
and she never returned how much are you
seeking from Epstein's estate I don't
even know what his entire estate is
worth but we're seeking significant
damages but Licata says going through
the courts won't make up for the abuse
she suffered a civil lawsuit then would
not give me back what I lost
Ella cada told us at least for her there
is no way to get peace now that Jeffrey
Epstein is dead we should note that both
Licata and a rose say they never
actually met ghilane Maxwell and the
three other women are listed as jane
doe's in the lawsuit because their
identities at this point are still
unknown that is something attorneys tell
us they hope to learn through what's
called the discovery process of this
civil case d'Alene Maxwell has never
been charged with a crime Gale and she
has always denied any wrongdoing well I
think you molla MS lakotas words are
haunting thank you very much